[Music]
on this thursday night
yet another glitch in delivering the
vaccine to canada
how did the liberal government let
things get so bad
how this country keeps falling behind as
others
forge ahead covet 19 compounds the
crisis for the homeless
how many homeless got to die before
somebody wakes up and does something
the drastic measures overwhelmed and
understaffed shelters
are taking and the calls to boycott the
beijing olympics
somebody has to break up a cycle of
retaliation and bullying
why canada isn't on board
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting
tonight robin gill good evening and
thank you for joining us
we begin with canada's rocky vaccine
rollout
after weeks of shortages the government
is warning provinces
more disruptions are on the horizon this
week's modernist shipment was slashed by
more than
20 percent now the government says the
next shipment
will also be reduced but it doesn't know
by how much or
why the cutbacks are happening as of
today just over one million doses have
been
administered across canada about 2.6
percent of the population
has received at least one dose that is
far behind many other countries but the
military general leading canada's
rollout
says he's confident the government will
make up ground
this is a long game and as we discussed
before
the ramp up planning is ongoing phase
two of the vaccine rollout
the ramp up we'll see a significant
increase in vaccine supply across canada
abigail beeman has tonight's top story
on the roadblocks
and the reassurances as canada struggles
with its vaccination campaign
we are now 34th in the world in the
vaccination of our population let that
sink in mr speaker
34th and dropping 34th
with news of another shipment shortage
thursday's moderna delivery had 22
percent less than originally planned
the next shipment on february 22nd will
be cut
too but canadian officials say we don't
know by how much
and we don't know why the quantities
that we expect to receive
remain to be confirmed by the
manufacturer
so at this time i i can't really tell
you what the quantity will be
but we do not expect to receive 249 000.
news of a different kind of delay too
after the procurement minister assured
everyone the special syringes that
helped get
six doses instead of five out of the
pfizer biontech bottle were coming this
week
two million or so and then the long ago
testing
anita anand didn't mention they need to
be tested first meaning provinces will
have to wait longer to use them
by february 15 according to our
estimation we'll be in america
will be in a position to distribute how
did the liberal government let things
get so bad why didn't they do what the
uk did
instead leaving us entirely dependent on
other countries our vaccine contracts
specify quarterly deliveries only
testifying at committee anand revealed
one detail of the highly secretive
vaccine contracts
manufacturers only have to meet delivery
requirements every three months
she also said the government pushed all
vaccine manufacturers about producing
vaccines in canada
like the deal just announced with
novovax but the rest
decided canada's capacity was too
limited pspc
frequently forcefully and aggressively
brought this issue to the table raised
it
with the manufacturers
beyond not yet knowing the total doses
we'll receive three weeks from now
provinces know
nothing about next month forte
acknowledges how difficult that makes
rollout planning and says he'll be able
to share details with provinces
soon about the first week of march but
like much of ottawa's vaccine plans he
says
that will be done in confidence abigail
beeman global news
ottawa the canadian government is urging
patients but other regions are racing
ahead with widespread vaccinations
eric sorenson looks at how other
countries are doing and why canada is
facing criticism
for dipping into a special global pool
of vaccines
vaccines are coming but in canada it
feels like the conveyor belt is grinding
to a halt
a slower rollout is one thing but
falling behind other countries is
another
the uk and the u.s are racing ahead with
vaccines per capita
both countries have large domestic
manufacturing capabilities
other g7 countries are behind around
three per 100 vaccinated so far
canada at 2.6 and likely to lag further
as manufacturers cut back on supplies
the eu is feeling the same frustration
europe
we europeans should be more efficient
said france's president
and germany's goals are almost identical
to canadas
by the end of the third quarter said
chancellor angela merkel we can offer a
vaccine to everyone
but most countries haven't started
vaccinating at all and some experts say
it shouldn't be a competition
we're only going to get through it if
the whole world gets through it
and so as a result we need to be focused
not only on
the race to be the most vaccinated in
canada but this is actually a race that
we all have to
run together still a sign of ottawa's
ambition to keep
up was its decision to draw from the
first supply of vaccines from kovacs
the international agency where wealthier
nations share vaccines with lower income
nations
our government will never apologize for
doing
everything in our power to get canadians
vaccinated as quickly as possible
it's all above board canada has
committed 440 million dollars to kovacs
half to pay for up to 15 million doses
for this country
the other half is for vaccine doses for
low and middle income countries
but to be at the front of that line
oxfam is angry the aid agency says
receiving one or two million doses isn't
going to solve
canada's vaccination challenges and it
is going to cause harm
elsewhere it is very surprising because
canada is the only
g7 uh country that is pulling in on this
deal are they breaking rules they're not
is it does it raise ethical questions
yes it really does actually
canada has already ordered the most
vaccine doses per capita in the world
and somehow is in the position of both
wanting as many vaccines as it can get
and seemingly falling behind in actually
getting them eric sorensen global news
toronto
with the growing spread of highly
infectious variants britain has launched
a trial to determine if covet 19
vaccines
can be mixed volunteers will be given
one shot of the astrozenica vaccine
followed by a booster of the pfizer
bioentech vaccine
or vice versa the first of its kind
trial will assess immune response not
the overall efficacy of shock
combinations preliminary results are
expected around june
a positive outcome could help vaccines
roll out with greater flexibility around
the world
astrazeneca is still under review in
canada
after months of rising case numbers
there are signs of progress in canada's
indigenous communities
according to indigenous services canada
over the last week
the number of active cases on reserves
has dropped by more than 50 percent
less than 2 000 people on reserves are
currently infected
that's the lowest number since early
december and the government says it's
making headway
getting vaccines into indigenous
communities
we're still on track to meet our end of
march objective of having administered
both doses of the vaccine to 75 percent
of people in regions that are considered
at higher risk
people are being urged not to let up on
public health guidelines
while vaccines are being ruled out
cruise ships won't be returning to
canadian waters any time soon
the government has extended its ban on
ships with more than 100 people
until february 2022 canadians are being
urged to avoid all travel on cruise
ships outside canada
until further notice
new federal travel rules are now in
place at canada's airports
international flights are now restricted
to four airports
vancouver calgary toronto and montreal
it's part of a push to discourage
travel and slow the spread of new
variants the government says it will
soon impose mandatory testing
and hotel quarantines in toronto at
least 20 residents of a large homeless
shelter have tested positive for the
virus
city officials say they've all been
moved to a recovery center
while they try to curb the outbreak
homeless people are struggling
everywhere right now
including quebec where it's bitterly
cold shelters have reached capacity in
montreal
a crisis that has also turned deadly
there are growing calls for the
government to step up and help but as
amanda jeliwicki reports
it's an uphill battle
a homeless man anxiously peeks inside
this new overnight warming tent in
downtown montreal
it's a place to sip a coffee relax and
survive
the bitter overnight cold the truth is
there will be others who who will die
unnecessarily
he's referring to rafael andre the
homeless inu man the tent is named for
he died last month found frozen in an
outdoor toilet
homelessness is no joke how many people
got
how many homeless got to die before
somebody wakes up
and does something andre's death is
brought to the forefront a crisis
affecting montreal's homeless
like never before with strict coveted
rules limiting capacity
shelters are overflowing and short
staffed
it is a very very very strong
and tough situation right now and severe
the city scrambled and built two
emergency shelters even those extra beds
aren't enough
we just opened this emergency space and
it is already full and we are refusing
people
already every night space good
some shelters have purchased igloos
self-contained
tents to keep street sleepers warm and
alive
this is a miracle man for real for every
one man
with covid hitting homeless and shelter
workers hard public health has
prioritized vaccinating the community
homeless advocates say compounding all
this stress
a fight with premier fosuela goat to
exempt homeless from the apm curfew
friends say andre was hiding from police
the night he died
they're scared they're scared to open a
toilet here let's say
and there's somebody in there dead as
for the warming tent
advocates say more are needed it's
really important right
uh that you know the people that are on
the streets
get the services and no one else passes
away
because with winter far from over they
fear what happened to andre
could happen again amanda jalawiki
global news
montreal new details are emerging
tonight around allegations involving
canada's former top soldier
general jonathan vance he's facing
allegations of engaging
in inappropriate sexual behavior in the
canadian armed forces
military police are now investigating
the case global news first reported
allegations that vance had an
intimate relationship with a female
subordinate including during his time as
chief of the defense staff it is also
alleged that he propositioned a junior
officer in 2012
before his appointment our ottawa bureau
chief mercedes stevenson joins us now
with the developments mercedes
robin global news has learned that the
canadian forces national
investigative surface the military
police who handle sensitive cases
have launched an investigation into the
allegations against general jonathan
vance
after meeting with one of the women
today global news has also learned that
defense minister harjit sajin's office
knew in 2018 of concerns about the
behavior
of canada's top soldier two government
sources tell global news the canadian
forces ombudsman at the time
gary walborne brought those concerns to
the minister's office
leaving sajin quote concerned a senior
government source also told global news
that sajin's office referred the matter
to the privy council office
believing they were the appropriate
authority but what happened after that
is still unclear sajin was grilled today
in question period
asked by conservatives to confirm
whether he briefed the prime minister
i have always ensured that any
allegations that are brought to my
attention
have have been reported to the
appropriate authorities to begin an
investigation regardless of rank or
position
a senior government source says the
prime minister in his office were
unaware of concerns about vance
and the allegations facing him before
they were reported by global news
vance denies all allegations of
inappropriate behavior
in the meantime there are growing
questions about how vance was vetted in
2015 by the harper government
before his appointment as chief of the
defense staff
and what all these allegations could
mean for operation honor
the military's mission to stamp out
sexual misconduct which vance was the
face of
no matter how well intentioned and how
valuable
that effort has been to date with
operation honor
you know this kind of an allegations i
think can only really seriously
undermine something
that seemed to be very important over
the last several years
mercedes you reported that the
subordinate officer says vance has
consistently been trying to call her
multiple times a day since you broke the
story what else have you learned about
their communication
the woman says she has felt pressured by
vance to say certain things that she
says
are not true like that they didn't have
sex vance acknowledged to global news
that he has called the woman
saying absolutely we have spoken but i
am not pressuring her
vance also said he has not asked her to
say anything untrue
and as far as that concern about abuse
of command authority in having a
relationship with a subordinate
vance has denied a sexual relationship
he says that he and the woman are old
friends
and that despite his being chief of the
defense staff while she was a junior
officer
he does not and i quote feel in any way
there is a power imbalance robin
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes
in the u.s the republicans are at war
with themselves
coming up their contentious vote on
whether to punish a georgia lawmaker
former u.s president donald trump won't
testify at his impeachment trial next
week his lawyers made that clear today
as for one of trump's biggest backers
the house of representatives has now
voted to remove
marjorie taylor greene from her
committee assignments
let's bring in our washington bureau
chief jackson proskow jackson how
significant is that
well robin this is unprecedented that
they would take steps like this against
a member of congress but it comes as the
republican party
grapples with the role of conspiracy
theorists in its own ranks
and the lingering influence of former
president trump
i was allowed to believe things that
weren't true seeking distance from her
own well-established beliefs
congresswoman marjorie taylor-green made
a defiant plea
but offered no apology will we allow the
media
that is just as guilty as q anon
of presenting truth and lies to divide
us green's tumultuous first month in
office has been defined by her years
spent promoting conspiracy theories
from q anon to bizarre anti-semitic
claims about space lasers
why are you supporting red flag gun laws
that attack our second amendment right
she harassed survivors of school
shootings and claimed the tragedies were
staged
in the weeks following the storming of
the capital calls for green to face
consequences have only grown louder
she claims that speaker pelosi is guilty
of treason
and then says quote it's a crime
punishable by death
is what treason is nancy pelosi is
guilty of treason we denounced
anything that we've seen that was said
in that past
and when republicans refused to strip
green of her committee assignments
democrats decided to use their majority
to do it
all the while greene has used the
controversy to fundraise
with the continued support of former
president donald trump
i think what it says is that people
think they can win elections by using
this messaging
this former republican congressman sees
dangerous days ahead
in a closed door caucus meeting on
wednesday it was republican liz cheney
not green who came under fire because of
cheney's support for impeaching trump
i just don't think you'll see a whole
lot of accountability for the awfulness
on january 6
with leaders who spread disinformation
as republicans claim green shouldn't be
punished for her conduct before she was
elected
they're also preparing to argue that a
now former president
can't be punished for his conduct while
in office
despite trump's refusal to testify
before the senate impeachment trial next
week
it is still possible he may face a
subpoena from the senate for his
testimony
it's also just as likely that they'll
use his refusal to speak
as evidence against him as that
impeachment trial gets underway next
week robin
jackson frasco in washington thanks
jackson still ahead
empty front pages lay out a dire message
about canadian journalism
did you notice something a little
strange when scanning today's headlines
in some cases they were blank not
because there was no news to tell
it's all part of a new campaign launched
by news media canada
the association represents the print and
digital media industry and is calling on
ottawa to take action
and impose laws against tech giants like
google and facebook
from taking use content from canadian
publishers and profiting
without paying it's uh
something that they've agreed to do in
in france and they are
we're working towards it in australia so
we think we need a made in canada
solution here you can find out more
about the call to action on our website
that's global news dot slash global
national
up next the bid to boycott beijing's
olympics and why the canadian olympic
committee
isn't on board
the president of tokyo's olympic
organizing committee has apologized
but refuses to resign over sexist
remarks
80 thrilled yoshiro mori said women talk
too much
and that meetings with female directors
can drag on
because everyone ends up saying
something maury has since acknowledged
the comments
were inappropriate the countdown to
beijing 2022
is officially on today marks one year to
go
until the winter games in china and
officials unveiled the designs for the
olympic
and paralympic torches but human rights
groups are taking a stand tonight
calling for a boycott to the games
because of china's abuses against ethnic
minorities and the detention of two
canadians
crystal commansing reports
beijing with the spotlight on china
activists fear the glimmer of gold will
have people turning a blind eye to the
country's human rights record
i was in the same protest or at least
call for boycott in 2008. we all kind of
kind of count out
what china wants us to do and i think
somebody has to break that cycle of
retaliation and bullying
china recently clawed back freedoms for
people in hong kong
freedoms protected under international
obligations
there are documented cases with
first-hand accounts of weaker muslims
being abused even
raped in chinese camps and the continued
detention of canadians michael kovrig
and michael spavor i think our
collective heart
breaks for what's happening to them and
yet
i think common sense should tell most of
us that
we're not going to embarrass the chinese
we're not going to shame them
into letting those two out of prison
david shoemaker says his
job is to support canada's athletes and
he demonstrated that
in an open letter writing in no way
are we at the canadian olympic committee
and canadian paralympics committee
trying to minimize what is happening in
china but a boycott
is not the answer canada didn't go to
the moscow games in 1980
and there have been many calls for
boycott since including the 2014 winter
games in sochi
and the 2008 games in beijing
when it comes to these games the
association for democracy in china
says canada shouldn't go at least giving
the people in china
some hope that people care outside
shoemaker lived in china and says he
gets it
but canada is going we did want to make
sure that the athletes understood no no
we're
we're behind you um we don't think you
should be used as
pawns in a dispute among nations
a clear message for athletes but one
that won't silence critics of the games
crystal gamson global news london
and that is global national for this
thursday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is spray valley
provincial park
in kananaskis country alberta we would
love to see your corner of this country
so please keep sending your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night